AT HOME.
>> Laura: GRADE TAPE.
GUTFELD, YOU ARE NEXT
♪ ♪
>> Greg: EXCELLENT.
I CAN'T READ THAT.
MY EYES DON'T GO THAT FAR.
YES, CLAP.
CLAP YOU MINIONS.
BUT DON'T LOOK AT ME WHEN YOU
ARE CLAPPING.
I WILL DESTROY YOU.
HAPPY WEDNESDAY, EVERYONE.
SHUT UP.
WHERE ARE WE IN THIS PANDEMIC?
IT IS HARD TO SAY.
SOME PEOPLE ARE ACTING LIKE
ADULTS, OTHERS ARE ACTING LIKE
CHILDREN.
AND STILL OTHERS ARE TREATING
CHILDREN LIKE ADULTS.
AND I'M NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
CNN PRODUCERS.
BUT FIRST OF THE PANDEMIC NEWS
AFFECTING OUR NATION'S POLITICAL
ELITE.
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., OUR STATE
CAPITAL, KAT, STRIP CLUBS HAVE
ALLEGEDLY BEEN WARNED ABOUT
THEIR DANCERS NOT WEARING MASKS.
IN A HARD-HITTING INVESTIGATIVE
REPORT, "THE DAILY CALLER" FINDS
THAT MULTIPLE STRIP CLUBS HAVE
VIOLATED THE MAYOR'S ORDER ON
MASKS.
THIS INCLUDES APPARENTLY THE
STRIPPERS WHO ARE SUPPOSED COVER
THEIR NOSES AND MOUTHS EVEN IF
THERE BUTTS AREN'T.
THIS IS A PERSONAL POINT.
I WOULD NOT MIND THE RULE ON THE
DATE TIME WHEN THE CLUBS AREN'T
BUILDING THE FIRST DURING.
>> DAY SHIFT.
>> Greg: BUT HOW CAN YOU ENJOY
A GOOD LAP DANCER IF YOU CAN'T
UNDERSTAND THE STRIPPERS STORY
ABOUT HOW SHE IS JUST DOING THE
TEMPORARILY TO PUT HERSELF
THROUGH MED SCHOOL.
AND WHAT KIND OF MASKS DO YOU
WEAR WHEN STRIPPING?
I'D ASKED STUART VARNEY.
AND NO, THEY DO NOT MAKE A 995
IN LATEX.
GOD KNOWS I HAVE LOOKED ALL OVER
PETE'S OFFICE.
BUT THE STRIPPERS, I BET THEY
ARE NOT PLEASED.
WE GO TO ONE FOR COMMENT.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: BEAR STRIP CLUB.
I CAN DREAM, TYRUS.
ON THE OTHER COAST, IT IS WORSE.
THE L.A. UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SAID IT IS BANNING STUDENTS FROM
WEARING CLOTH MASKS.
THEY MUST NOW WHERE WELL FITTED,
NONCLOTH MASKS WITH A NEWSWIRE
AT ALL TIMES.
INCLUDING OUTDOORS.
WELL, AT LEAST I WILL PREPARE
THEM FOR A FUTURE AND STRIPPING.
OR A SMASH AND GRAB WHICH ARE
BOTH VERY POPULAR LOCATIONS IN
L.A. RIGHT NOW.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO DO?
I GUESS IT IS TIME FOR --
"GREG GOT FIELDS DESPERATE RAN
TO END THIS [BLEEP]."
>> Greg: HERE IS ONE THING WE
DIDN'T EXPECT.
HOW AUTHORITARIAN IS AND WAS
UNLEASHED IN BUSINESSES BY OUR
GOVERNMENT.
THE GOVERNMENT MADE THE
REGULATIONS WHICH PUT IT ON
WAITRESSES AND HOSTESSES AND
MATTRESS ELEMENT OF FORCE YOU TO
COMPLY.
AND IT WAS UP TO THE COPS TO
ARREST YOU IF YOU DID.
SO WHILE THE GOVERNMENT LOOKS
BENIGN, IT IS YOUR NEIGHBORS WHO
BECAME THE ENFORCERS.
WHAT BETTER WAY TO UNIFY THE
NATION'S PEOPLE AND FORCE THEM
INTO THE ROLES OF THE COPS AND
ROBBERS?
YOU CAN DIVIDE PEOPLE ANY MORE
EFFICIENTLY WITH A TABLE SAW.
I HAVE TRIED.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT QUESTION MIKE
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE TO.
PEOPLE BECAME OKAY WITH
INCREMENTAL AUTHORITARIANISM
LIKE THE FROG IN THIS LOW
BOILING WATER, AND EXPERIMENT
I'M SURE FAUCI INVENTED.
THEY ENJOY THE MOMENT WITHOUT
KNOWING HOW IT WOULD END MY
GIVING JESSE WATTERS HIS OWN
SHOW.
THEY GAVE THEM NOXIOUS PEOPLE
POWER.
YOU SEE COME AUTHORITARIANISM
DOESN'T JUST SHOW UP ONE DAY
SCREAMING HEY, EVERYONE, I AM A
AUTHORITARIAN PURITY COMES
GRADUALLY I CAN UNDETECTED
MALIGNANT TUMOR, IT JUST GROWS.
WHO KNEW THE ENTERTAINERS AND
JOURNALISTS, USUALLY CONSIDERED
SKEPTICS OF POWER, WOULD
ACTUALLY EMBRACE BECOMING THE
MAN.
>> THIS IS WHAT I CALL FACE MASK
FREAK OUTS.
I'VE MADE IT CLEAR.
I CANNOT STAND SEEING PEOPLE
WALKING AROUND WITHOUT A MASK.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
TO PROTECT OUR FAMILY.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT, BUT
STAY AWAY FROM EVERYBODY.
>> HOW DARE YOU BE SO FLIPPANT.
>> IT'S ALSO A QUESTION OF
MANNERS.
GOOD MANNERS.
>> YOU SCARE PEOPLE BY NOT
WEARING A MASK --
>> Greg: OH, AND SO THE REBELS
HAVE BECOME THE ESTABLISHMENT.
CHOOSING FEAR OVER RISK
MANAGEMENT.
THE RISK MANAGEMENT IS NOT JUST
BRAVE AND SENSIBLE.
THE WORLD IS NOT YOUR HOUSE YOU
CAN MAKE CHILDPROOF.
AND YOU CAN'T LEAVE IT TO BOZOS
WHO SEE RISK ONLY BEING
ACCEPTABLE AT 0.
THAT DESTROY SOCIETY.
IT WOULD HAVE TO LOCK YOURSELF
IN THE BASEMENT TO SURVIVE.
AND LIKE I SAID AND JOE DEVITO'S
ROBOT GIRLFRIEND, THAT IS NO
LIFE.
BUT IS HARD TO EXPLAIN THIS TO
PEOPLE AND LOVE OF THEIR OWN
AUTHORITY.
YOU CANNOT WRESTLE FEAR AWAY
FROM THAT.
LIKE A CAT, IT IS TOO IMPORTANT
TO THEM.
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE RIGHT NOW
AREN'T RISK MANAGERS, THEY ARE
ASS PROTECTORS, TRYING TO KEEP
THEMSELVES FROM BEING SUED OR
ARRESTED.
AND THEY DESERVE RESPECT -- THEY
HAVE BEEN APPLYING THE SAME RISK
PROFILE AND ONE PERSON TO THE
NEXT FOUL NEXT WITHOUT ANYBODY
KNOW MIKE ANY CLARITY.
A 10-YEAR-OLD SKATEBOARDER SOME
HIVE FOUL
--
SO THEY BOTH MUST MASK UP AND
OUTSIDE.
IT IS LIKE HIRING A TAX
ACCOUNTANT FOR YOUR 6-YEAR-OLD
WHO RAN A LEMONADE STAND BECAUSE
IT IS APRIL AND YOU NEVER KNOW.
THE FACT IS, THE GOVERNMENT
ISN'T CRAZY ABOUT TELLING YOU
ABOUT YOUR LOWER RISK PROFILE
BECAUSE THEN YOU WON'T ADHERE TO
THEIR UNIFORM RULES.
SO THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO HAVE
UNIFORM RISK WHICH IS A UNIFORM
LIGHT THAT CREATES A UNIFORM
PANIC.
THAT'S WHY THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT
OBESITY AND OTHER METRICS ABOUT
HEALTH.
THEY PREFER YOU SCARED.
IT WASN'T YOU OR ME WHO MADE THE
VIRUS AND LET IT OUT.
IT WAS THEM.
IF IT WERE YOU, YOU WOULD BE
RECEIVING YOUR DINNER TO A SLOT
AND YOUR CELL DOOR FOR THE REST
OF YOUR LIFE.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT IT
WAS FINE TO INCREASINGLY
VALIDATE AN CONTAGIOUSNESS OF
CORONAVIRUS' AND WUHAN ARE NOW
LECTURING US ABOUT RISK.
IT IS NUTS.
LET'S HEAR FROM BRETT.
>> GENERATE 27, FAUCI IS TOLD
HAS BEEN INDIRECTLY FUNDING THE
WUHAN LAB THROUGH ECO-HEALTH
ALLIANCE.
U.S.-BASED SCIENTIFIC NONPROFIT
THAT HAD BEEN WORKING WITH NOVEL
CORONAVIRUS'.
JANUARY 31ST, DR. CHRISTIAN
ANDERSON, A NOTED VIROLOGIST AT
THE SCRIPPS LAB, PRIVATELY TELL
FAUCI THAT AFTER DISCUSSIONS
WITH HIS COLLEAGUES, SOME OF
COVID-19'S FEATURES POTENTIALLY
LOOKED ENGINEERED.
AND, "THE GENOME IS INCONSISTENT
WITH EXPECTATIONS FROM
EVOLUTIONARY THEORY."
>> Greg: SO, WHEN WILL THEY BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
I PREDICT IT WILL HAPPEN WHEN
KAT BEAT TYRUS AND
ARM WRESTLING.
NOW THEY TALK ABOUT A NEW
VARIANT OF OMICRON.
>> WE CAN ADD ANOTHER VARIANT
ARRIVES ON THE THAT LOOKS MORE
LIKE OMICRON THAN PREVIOUS
VARIANCES.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
IT'S THE WAR WITHOUT END, A
FRAMEWORK.
SO AS ONE LEAVES, ANOTHER SHOWS
UP IT AS ONE BATTLE FADES,
RETURNED WITH A NEW ONE.
IT IS COVID.
IT WAS ALSO CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT IS ALSO RACISM.
YOU WILL KEEP EATING MY PAYING
FOR AN EMERGENCY THAT NEVER
ENDS.
AND WE SEE HOW THAT GOES ON
FOREVER.
VIETNAM, AFGHANISTAN, THE DRUG
WAR, "SEX AND THE CITY."
THE ONLY WAY TO STOP THAT
MADNESS IS IF YOU DO THE
STOPPING.
PUBLIC SENTIMENT AND DID THOSE
WARS, AND IT IS TIME TO DO THE
SAME THING NOW BECAUSE IT IS NOT
ME WHO DECIDES WHEN THIS ENDS.
IT IS YOU.
YOU UNDERSTAND RISK.
YOU FOLLOWED THE SCIENCE.
AS WE CLOSE IN ON FEBRUARY 1ST,
IT IS TIME FOR SOME GOOD
OLD-FASHIONED GROUP CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE.
DON'T WEAR THE MASK.
HELP BURN THE THING.
THAT WORKED WITH AND DRAFT CARDS
IN THE 1960s.
AND ALSO THE HOUSE HAD BURNED
DOWN BECAUSE THE VOICES TOLD ME
TO.
WHEN SOMEONE ASKS YOU TO READ
MASK, SAY THAT IS NOT FOLLOWING
THE SIGNS AND THEN LEAVE.
GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WE ALL DO THIS TOGETHER AND A
ENDS.
BECAUSE OF YOU DON'T DO IT,
KNOWING WELL, AND THEN WE ARE
ALL SCREWED.
HOPEFULLY AT THE STRIP CLUB.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
THEY CALL HIS JOKES "BITS"
BECAUSE THE LAUGHS ARE SO TINY.
WRITER AND COMEDIAN, JOE DEVITO.
SHE TALKS SO FAST HER MOUTH GETS
SHIN SPLINTS.
"OUTNUMBERED" CO-HOST, EMILY
COMPAGNO.
SHE'S THE GIRL OF YOUR DREAMS --
IF YOU WANT A BLONDE FREDDY
KRUEGER.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, KAT TIMPF.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR HIS HOUSE,
JUST CLIMB UP THE BEANSTALK.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION,
TYRUS.
EMILY, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE.
>> Greg: YOU LOOK GOOD IN
LEATHER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Greg: NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
CAN PULL OFF LEATHER.
YOU SHOULD SEE ME WHEN I GET
HOME.
BECAUSE IT'S VERY TIGHT.
HOW DO PEOPLE AND THIS?
I KEEP GIVING THIS ADVICE,
EMILY, BUT I AM NOT REALLY
GIVING PRACTICAL ADVICE AND
SAYING YOU GUYS HAVE TO END
THIS.
BUT IT IS WHEN ONE PERSON DOES
SOMETHING AND ANOTHER PERSON
SEES THAT PERSON DO SOMETHING.
AND THEN THE ACTIVITY BECOMES
CONTAGIOUS.
>> AND I THINK YOU DID PROPOSE A
SOLUTION AND YOUR MONOLOGUE WHEN
HE SAID IT IS ABOUT PUBLIC
SENTIMENT.
IN THE PUBLIC SHOWING UP AND
STANDING UP IN THE WAY OF
SYPHILIS OBEDIENCE AND
NONVIOLENT WAY.
SO TO THE MASK POINT, AND IN
L.A., AND LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
DISTRICT, NOW I HAVE TO A
CERTAIN KIND OF MASK.
WITH A NOSE THING.
AND THAT MEANS THAT IS
INDICATING THE PRIORITY THEY ARE
OF THE TEACHERS UNION AND THE
SCHOOLS THEY ARE, THE PRIORITY
IS NOT ON MENTAL HEALTH, IT IS
NOT ON THE FACT AND IN THE LAST
MR. LUNT THEY'VE SEEN MORE
REFERRALS FOR MENTAL HEALTH,
MORE REFERRALS FOR DISCIPLINARY
REFERRALS, STUDENT ON STUDENT
AND STUDENT ON TEACHER'S
VIOLENCE AND THEY HAVE IN ANY
YEAR COMBINED AND I WAS JUST ONE
SEMESTER.
SO THIS COULD HAVE REPORTED
FEELING -- 3 OUT OF 4 -- NOTIONS
OF SUICIDE.
THEY BLAME SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY BLAME THE LOCKDOWN.
THERE ARE SOME NEW THINGS
HAPPENING THAT THESE KIDS ARE IN
AGONY YET THAT SHOWS THE
PRIORITY WHICH IS CONFORMITY TO
THOSE SPECIFIC TYPE OF MASKS.
I JUST LIKE FLYING ON AIRPLANES,
AIRPLANES ALL OF SUDDEN GOOD TO
BE INCUMBENT ON THE TEACHERS.
OH, THE STUDENT DOESN'T HAVE
THAT AND WE ARE GOING TO SEND
THEM HOME AND THEY ARE TOTALLY
LOSING THE FOREST FOR THE TREES.
IF THEY CARED ABOUT KIDS, IT
WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
BUT THE POINT IS, THE PARENT
SAID NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IF THERE WERE SOME KIND OF
ACTUAL STANDING UP FOR
THEMSELVES, THAT IS THE ONLY WAY
THAT THIS IS GOING TO CHANGE.
>> Greg: THE ANTIMASK PARTY,
JOE.
I CAN FEEL IT.
I CAN SMELL THE CHANGE IN THE
AIR.
EITHER THAT OR IT IS KAT.
>> SHOCKING HE WENT WITH ME
THERE.
>> NOW IT IS IN THE STRIP CLUBS
I THINK IT IS GAME OVER PURE
NONSENSE THAT -- THE ONLY TIME I
WENT TO SEE ANYTHING COVERED UP
IN A STRIP CLUB IS IF THERE I
HAVE TO STOP GOING ON THE ONE
SHIFT.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE
NOW PEOPLE, THIS IS THEIR
MOMENT.
PEOPLE TO BE A TYRANT.
THEIR MOMENT OF FREAK OUT AND IT
IS WHAT MAKES THEM FEEL GOOD IS
TO PUT THE PHONE DOWN ON
SOMEBODY.
AND WE ARE SEEING IN SCHOOLS.
IT IS BECOMING CHILD ABUSE AT
THIS POINT.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THE SCHOOLS
WHERE RICH PEOPLE'S KIDS GO,
THEY ARE NOT MAKING THEM WEAR
MASKS.
WE SEE IT WHEN WE SEE THE FANCY
PEOPLE ARE OUT AND THE PEOPLE
ATTENDING TO THEM ARE WEARING
MASKS AND GLOVES AND ALL THAT.
IT IS TERRIBLE, AND IT IS
ABUSIVE TO CHILDREN BECAUSE
CHILDREN NEED TO SEE FACES WHEN
THEY'RE YOUNG, THEY NEED TO HAVE
THIS INTERACTION.
THAT CAN'T BE MADE UP AND IF
PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE ME, LOOK UP
THE REMAINING ORPHANAGES WITH A
RAISE THE CHILDREN AS IF THEY
WERE LIVESTOCK IN THE CHILDREN
WERE DAMAGED FOREVER.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, NOT THAT I
KNOW A LOT ABOUT ROMANIANS, BUT
THEIR DICTATOR WAS GIVING A
SPEECH WHEN HE WAS IN POWER ONE
DAY AND IT TOOK ONE PERSON AND
BACK TL "SHUT UP" AND EVERYONE
ELSE STARTED YELLING AND BEFORE
YOU KNOW IT HE WAS EXECUTING
THEM AND 20 BARS AND NO PEOPLE
WERE FREE
>> Greg: DO YOU CARE TO
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION MIKE
>> WORSE THINGS TO CATCH AT A
STRIP CLUB --
>> Greg: ASK HUNTER BIDEN.
>> OR ANOTHER GUY I KNOW.
BUT I DIGRESS.
THE GREAT POINT ABOUT THE MASKS.
THAT IS TRUE, YOU CAN CATCH
CHILDREN AT A STRIP CLUB WHICH I
WOULD ARGUE I WOULD TAKE COVID
ANY TIME.
BUT I LOVE THEM.
WHAT IS FRUSTRATING TO ME IS THE
MASK IS LITERALLY IF YOU FOLLOW
THIS SCIENCE, IT IS FOR YOU.
I FEEL LIKE WE KEEP REPEATING
OURSELVES.
DOESN'T KEEP YOU FROM GETTING
IT.
AND MAYBE CAN KEEP YOU FROM
SPREADING THE THING, BUT YOU CAN
KEEP THE MASK ON 24/7.
YOU CAN DO IT.
GOING AIRPLANE, SURE.
PUT YOUR MASK OVER YOUR NOSE AS
YOU KNOW AS YOU ARE ASHAMED FOR
IT.
BUT IF YOU ORDER A SPRAY, YOU
CAN TAKE IT OFF.
SO LITERALLY IF YOU HAVE A
LOLLIPOP IN YOUR MOUTH IN AN
AIRPLANE, YOUR MASK IS OFF THE
ENTIRE FLIGHT OR UNTIL HOW MANY
LICKS DOES IT TAKE TO GET TO A
TOOTSIE POP.
NOW IT IS 147.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AND IT
IS FRUSTRATING AND YOU SEE
PEOPLE FRUSTRATED AND IT IS
CAUSING SO MUCH DIVISION.
PEOPLE ARE SO ANGRY WITH EACH
OTHER.
FIGHTS ARE BREAKING OUT AND
PEOPLE ARE ATTACKING EACH OTHER.
WE SAW THE ELEVATOR THING FROM
LAST NIGHT.
I THINK YOUR POINT IS SPOT ON.
UNTIL EVERYBODY SAYS ENOUGH, IT
IS GOING TO CONTINUE BE THIS
WAY.
BECAUSE WERE GOING TO HAVE 17
VERSIONS OF OMICRON.
>> Greg: IT IS LIKE BATTLES IN
A WAR THAT THEY WANT TO STAY IN
A BATTLE.
NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER BATTLE
COMING UP.
IT'S THE BATTLE FOR THIS.
THAT'S WHY I FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN
THIS WEIRD --
>> THEY ARE GOING TO RUN OUT OF
NAMES.
GOING TO BE LIKE OMICRON 17,
COVID-19.
>> Greg: SUB VARIANT.
KAT, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
MASKING IN STRIP CLUBS?
>> I THINK LIKE MOST THINGS IT
SHOULD BE UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL
STRIPPER.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALLOW MORE IN
STRIP CLUBS.
THEN MOST DO.
IT IS RIDICULOUS.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE, JUST LIKE
MASKING KIDS UP DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE, ESPECIALLY OUTSIDE.
BUT NOBODY THINKS THAT.
LIKE THERE IS NO WAY THAT
EVERYBODY THAT IS IN CHARGE OF
RUNNING THE LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
DISTRICT ACTUALLY THINKS THAT WE
NEED TO MASK KIDS OUTSIDE.
PRETTY SURE EVERYBODY PROBABLY
KNOWS THAT BUT THEY ARE TOO
AFRAID TO SAY SOMETHING.
WHICH I GUESS ISN'T BAD IN YOUR
OWN LIFE BUT IT'S EVEN WORSE
WHEN IT'S KIDS' LIVES.
THIS PANDEMIC HAS DONE THE
IMPOSSIBLE.
IT HAS MADE ME CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE'S KIDS.
>> SPEAKING OF WIRE, HAS ANYONE
NOT SEEN THE AMERICAN CLASSIC
QUESTION MIKE YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU PUT WIRES OVER
YOUR NOSE?
EVERYONE GETS CROSS EYED.
HE DIDN'T SEE THAT?
UP TO GRAB
>> Greg: I LEARNED SOMETHING
NEW EVERY DAY.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE
SUPER BOWL.
NO ONE IS GOING TO BE MASKED.
EMILY?
>> I WANTED TO SAY -- >> IF YOU
LIKE IT.
SPEAK I DID NOT.
AT THAT ONE STRIP CLUB THEY HAVE
MAGNUMS ON SATURDAY NIGHT AND
WANTED TO SAY THAT --
SPEAK OF IT'S